- America's first roller coaster ride,
which opened in 1884 at
Coney Island, Brooklyn,
and capable of a top speed
of only six miles per hour,
and then we have the choice
E, which is no error.
So let's think about if there
is an error here, where it is.
So, America's first roller coaster ride,
which opened in 1884 at
Coney Island, Brooklyn,
and capable of a top speed
of only six miles per hour.
So the way it's written right now,
we never even get to knowing
what America's first roller coaster did.
Both of these clauses,
which opened in 1884
at Coney Island, Brooklyn,
that's one that kind of describes
America's first roller coaster,
and then another clause,
and capable of a top speed
of only six miles per hour.
That also, the way it's written,
it's still kind of just describing
America's first roller coaster,
but it didn't say what
it's actually doing.
If I were to say where the error is,
if I'm trying to convey this meaning,
I would have said something like,
America's first roller coaster ride,
which opened in 1884 at
Coney Island, Brooklyn,
was capable of a top speed
of only six miles per hour.
So I would have changed and capable of.
I would have changed
this to was capable of,
was capable of a top speed
of only six miles per hour.
So the error here is in part B.